et
bonsoir invité de la semaine en
aquitaine aujourd'hui le bordelais jean
lacouture on devrait peut-être dire
l'aquitaine paris écrivain journaliste
biographe des plus grands de notre pays
je dirais malraux mauriac léon blum
pierre mendès france
et puis ce gigantesque énorme de gaulle
en trois volumes voilà le troisième dans
le dernier est sorti d'on conseil
récemment un peu votre borgia de gaulle
jean lacouture vous êtes son machiavel
ah non parce que machiavel avait une
influence très directs sur césar borgia
tandis que moi le prince je le considère
mais de l'extérieur et je peux vous
garantir que je n'ai jamais eu la
moindre influence sur général de gaulle
site arte vous l'ayez que vous l'ayez
cru non je crois même un essai de
démonter les rouages les arcades du
pouvoir alors en effet d'une certaine
façon ce livre pourrait être pourrait
s'intituler si tenté que la comparaison
de son fait crainte
affreusement écrasante pour moi le
prince est vrai mais ce ne sont pas les
les conseils donnés au prince c'est là
la photographie de des comportements du
prince avant d'aller plus avant dans
notre émission je vous propose tout de
suite un petit portrait de jean
lacouture 10 par mois mais il a été
réalisé par l'ensemble de notre
rédaction vous propose de l'écouter tout
de suite ils ont de la personnalité
basque est très originale très puissante
regardez bien cet homme profil d'oiseaux
de proie faciès taillé à coups de serpe
avec des yeux plus fin que la bouche
encore comme si la parole prudente
mesurer sans cesse retenu au bord de la
mémoire scrutatrice de l'analyse la plus
sérieuse et détaillé que des noms le
regard venez freiné en permanence
contenir un tempérament de feu marché
mercure don quichotte et sancho un vrai
gascon en tous les cas avec ses élans
contradictoires rugby tiers-monde
malraux tauromachie mauriac qui le
fascine par sa fougue austère son amour
du sud ouest quelques images quelques
quelques moues chose qui bouge autour de
moi et puis ceux de gaulle gigantesque
comme l'ombre du commandeur
d'une vie qui n'avait pas besoin de
cette grandeur là mais après tout la
couture n'êtes vous pas une vraie public
à vous tout seul
bon en fait réponse à tout cela jorda
culture on c'est un portrait extrêmement
gentille vraiment tout à fait tout à
fait jeudi club le dire que vous êtes
devenus gaullistes petit peu sur sur 100
chevaux parce que je me sens vraiment
moi très peu de sang chaud d'ailleurs
don quichotte ce serait vraiment
beaucoup de prétention intention de ma
part non je dirais aussi un tout petit
peu sur le la formule finale que le
général voulez vous entendez par cette
caricature et l'intervention que vous
faites que de gaulle me me direz vous
aussi vous êtes venu vous est venue
jusqu'à moi oui or je peux dire que je
suis arrivé plus près du général que je
n'étais partie c'est vrai que l'étude
la fréquentation de ce grand homme
l'étude des dossiers des des crises
qu'il a traversées m'a conduit à
comprendre en effet mieux le son
comportement au cours de quarante années
d'histoire de france et que c'est vrai
que je suis aujourd'hui plus proches de
ceux de ce qu'on pourrait appeler un
gaulliste je encore que je ne puisse pas
me définir comme gaulliste je ne le
crois pas je crois pas l'être devenu en
tout le monde l'est aujourd'hui toute
manière vous pouvez vous tranquilliser
on peut se ranger partout on a fait
allusion à votre visage
vos racines sont elles pour quelque
chose là dedans cette stature qui est la
vôtre
elles sont landaise sens et je suis
bordelais de plusieurs de plusieurs
générations mais ma famille vient du sud
des landes pense du côté de la chalosse
parlant il ya beaucoup de la couture
dans cette région aux gens qui viendront
le mans la couture veux tu veux dire un
petit un petit terrain espagne 2
je viens de petits propriétaires
terriens d'il ya une vingtaine de
génération comme de vraisemblablement je
ne suis pas passé par le bo biliaire moi
j'aime bien je ne revendique aucun aucun
chevalier d'un coup sur la couture nous
allons être coupé je vous prie je vous
propose de retrouver tout à l'heure
après les actualités régionales tout de
suite la pub
alain chollon pour les actualités
régionales et nous 19h35